[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das rezept für diese erdbeertorte die
sieht nicht nur optisch super hübsch aus
sondern sich schmeckt auch richtig
lecker und auch wenn das sehr aufwendig
aussieht ist die zubereitung eigentlich
total easy
wir benötigen 800 gramm erdbeeren bei
teelöffel vanille extrakt 20 bis 30
gramm puderzucker 600 gramm kalte
schlagsahne zwei pakete milchschnitte da
sind jeweils zehn stück drin 600 gramm
schmandt sechs teelöffel seiner tat für
die sahne sowie sechs teelöffel seiner
fahrt für den schwanz und ein esslöffel
cacau desweiteren benötigen wir einen
leckeren schoko biscuit das rezept dafür
gibt es bereits auf einem kanal
ich habe diesmal zwei drittel des clips
genommen in einer 24 cm springform
gebacken und einmal in der hälfte durch
geteilt
für die creme wird zuallererst die kalte
schlagsahne in eine rührschüssel begeben
und anschließend rica 30 sekunden lang
angeschlagen danach kommen die sechs
teelöffel seiner party zu und die sahne
wird komplett steif geschlagen
die sahne lager ich in der zwischenzeit
im kühlschrank so lange geht es weiter
mit dem schwanz
den gebe ich in eine rührschüssel geben
dass vanille extrakt hin so unverhohlen
das einmal kurz hier gebe ich auch noch
donnerstag hinzu und war über das kurz
und da sieht man dass die themen auch
schon etwas fester wird im nächsten
schritt mache ich dann in einem
teilhaber weiter
hier hole ich nochmal alles auf dem
schneebesen raus damit auch nichts
verschwendet wird an dieser stelle bitte
auch noch das puderzucker mit unter
rühren an dem tag habe ich nicht gemacht
im nachhinein empfehle ich euch doch und
dann nur noch die sahne unterheben und
dann ist die creme auch schon fertig den
teil der erdbeeren der dann auf den
kuchen kommt in habe ich hier halbiert
und den anderen teil den habe ich
geviertelt und jetzt geht's auch schon
an stapeln schichten und dekorieren der
pforte den tortenboden auf eine
tortenplatte legen dann ein tortenring
drumherum geben und die milch schnitte
auf jeden fall durch zwei feiern weil so
kann man sie viel drumherum liegen da
gibt's auch gar nicht viel zu erzählen
einfach die milch-schnitte drum herum
legen immer wieder den tortenring
zurechtrücken und am besten auch die
milch-schnitte immer wieder ein bisschen
aneinander schieben damit man keine
mücken habe
um den kreis zu schließen müsste die
letzte milchschnitte eventuell noch
keiner schneiden
als nächstes wird ein viertel der seinen
schwanz creme auf die torte gegeben und
blatt verstrichen
[Musik]
anschließend die hälfte der getöteten
erdbeeren darauf verteilen
[Musik]
darauf kommen dann ein weiteres viertel
der banisch band creme und wird noch mal
glatt verstrichen
[Musik]
nun wird der zweite bizkit boden drauf
gegeben und mit den händen immer schön
an drücken
darauf wird dann seine stimme gegeben
und mit dem löffel glatt verstrichen
[Musik]
darauf dann die zweite hälfte der
gefährten erdbeeren verteilen und mit
seinem schwanz film abschließen
für die optik wird jetzt noch gleichauf
darüber gegeben
ich habe hier bei kakao genommen ihr
könnt aber auch trinker kauf verwenden
als letzten schritt werden dann noch die
halbierten erdbeeren darauf verteilt und
dann ist die torte auch schon fertig die
kombination der torte erdbeer sahne
schoko und milch schnitte ist einfach
optimal
und wenn ihr es nach machen wollt dann
würde ich mich über bilder freuen auf
instagram könnt ihr auch gerne per
e-mail schicken dann poste ich die auf
meinem instagram account und ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal ob ich
es gibt